supporters of President fornia simply
celebrated his reenact Shinto a fourth
term following 40 on Sunday the election
Empire declared the landslide win would
extend our sympathy in year rule for
another five years his win also extend
his family's rule closer to 60 years
Simba succeeded his late father who
ruled for 38 years
season the moment the president
addressed his opponents who have accused
him of election fraud stop improvising
stop inventing imaginary numbers and let
us submit ourselves to the judgment of
the people of Togo the people have
decided we've come out victorious it's
always possible to contest for whatever
happens victory is ours
the run up with 18 percent of the vote
opposition leader guerre yo Mikoto says
the election was stolen seconds first of
all the coalition rejects the results as
announced we are calling observers and
the international community to use their
unique position to give the true account
of this election to the togolese people
I call on you to mobilize to protest
this election fraud and defend their
world the fraud allegations are raising
widespread concerns in Togo following
violent protests two years ago although
businesses reopen the day after the
election results were announced the
opposition called for street protests is
setting people on edge here many have
not forgotten the outcome of
demonstrations in 2017 and 2018 against
President Lee Assembly's plan to change
the Constitution and run for a fourth
term for now the president's supporters
celebrate that win
and the opposition complain the next few
days are crucial to see if opposition
supporters answer the call to protest
and how security forces respond comedy
Chris al Jazeera know me